ابراج الصيرات هنا كما نتابعكم هذا
البرج يب انه قصف لاحد ابراج عن جلوت التي
في تتعد عننا امطار معدوده فقط حاول
الزملاء الصحفيون نقل صوره الخبر من هذه
المنطقه لكن يصعب علينا التقدم اكثر في
هذه المنطقه ضراوه القصف وشده هذا
القمع الى قصف مدفعي
استمعو الان الى الصف العريف في هذه
المنطقه يعني سنحاول ان نخلي هذه
المنطقه ط مين
ضرب اطلع تعال نطلع من هنا تعال نطلع من ه
تعال نطلع من ه نشاهد المواطنين
الان بداوا بالنزوح الى المناطق التي
اعلنت
اس
عبر المنشورات الورقيه التي ارسلوها الى
هذا
المكان شعب قاعد بتهجر اطلع فرشات على ناس
قاعده بتنز نساء اطفال ولا واحد عارف لا
يدبر على حاله اللي بيقعد في خيم واللي
بيقعد قاعد عند في حواصل عند الناس ايش
بدك تتوقع اكثر من هيك الدبابه بترمي
علينا قذايف وطلعنا من تحت القداي الله
اكبر على الدول العربيه حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل كل واحد ما بتطلع له الشعب الغلبان
لشعب غزه يحنوا علينا يحنوا على الاطفال
يما مبسوطين علينا هيك نحن نقول الى كل
الضمائر الحيه في العالم اوقفوا هذا
النزيف اوقفوا هذه الهجره الداخليه هؤلاء
الاطفال وهؤلاء النساء الذين لا يعرفون
الى اين يذهبون اين نذهب اين يعني نعيش
هنا العشرات من المواطنون لازالوا ينزحون
طبعا نشاهد عشرات السيارات والشاحنات
وحتى البهائم تواصل نقل المواطنين الى
المناطق الامنه في دير البلح وهنا نسمع
اصوات القصف المستمر على هذه المنطقه من
قبل مدفعيه وطائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مع تواجد العشرات حقيقه من طائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيلي في سماء هذه
انا انا كمواطن فلسطيني ايش ارتكبت جرم
انه انا يصير في زي هيك فهمني هذا الضمير
الميت يجب ان يصحوا من اجل الاطفال ومن
اجل الشيوخ ومن اجل النساء وقفوا القتل
وقفوا الدمار اقفوا هذه العنجهيه الكبيره
وين حقوق الانسان يطلع هالاطفال وه النساء
للعالم كله يطلعنا يا بني رحمه يحم علينا
يا خال بكف تهريب تشريد لهال الابطال
jag